claudine la seule prétendante d'eric
l'avait quitté après seulement une
journée
car il lui avait préféré la télé
préférée la télé à sa meuf cette semaine
termina donc tout fait pour les rats
bulbes rabab al mahdi embauché pour les
rabibocher vont ils réussir à se
remettre ensemble
regardez vive nous laisse nous sommes en
groupes rivaux à angers le coup je suis
donnerait une chance sur combien pour
que ça reparte avec claudine
sur 100 que ça veut rigoler claudine 64
apple se blesse et c'est que les textos
que tu lui donnes que tu lui envoies à
64 appel où elle a pas répondu tu peux
le faire défiler à moustoir bonjour je
pars faire mon choix j'ai mal aux dents
je mange des steaks frites
non mais c'est quoi ce texto je dis la
vérité et sa foule de ma gueule à sa
famille est ce que tu as vu ça j'adore
tu fais je t'aime bah oui j'ai dit je
t'aime bien sûr j'ai dit c'est bien que
je t'avais dit que j'étais capable de
dire je t'aime va réussir à rabibocher
claudine et sur les réseaux sociaux
karine s'est fait terminée elle s'est
fait fracasser voilà non mais parce que
son attitude n'a pas du tout plu ah oui
au vu du comportement des risques jugés
déplacés pour certains puisqu'il eut
envoyé 64 sms sans réponse
la plupart des téléspectateurs ne
regroupe comprennent pas pourquoi karine
lemarchand insiste autant l'amour est
dans le pré que karine l'escaudinois
d'eric merci pour l karine le marchand
qui dit à claudine comment se conduire
face à éric on rêve claudine a eu raison
de partir aucune femme ne restera qu'à
moi alors j'ai beaucoup pris c'est vrai
que quand vous êtes devant eric d'appel
jean michel c'est ce qu'à choquer les
gens et je le comprends
elle transforme et claudie ans coupable
mais réalisé c'est toi tu as pris samedi
les gens sur les régionales a pris sa
décision
bah si tu as pris ta décision trop vite
ce que t'es pas emballé je te demande de
réfléchir je reviendrai vers toi pour ça
elle appuie sa décision n'en veut pas le
mec qui fait du harcèlement
soixante quatre corps une personne vraie
bombe à 64 fois on n'assiste pas à la
paix de la nuit tout moi je pense que là
la présentatrice quand elle demande donc
aux candidats leur ressentiment
elle prend réception de style hardy et
c'est aux téléspectateurs de juger si
oui ou non ils doivent se rabibocher
mais je pense pas que ce soit la
meilleure placée pour donner des
commentaires et des conseils pour ceux
de ce qu'il s'agit de des histoires de
couple et d'amour et moi je pense que
c'est pas du tout son rôle d'aller voir
la dame et lui de la faire culpabiliser
alors qu'elle est déjà mal dans sa peau
tu peux pas dire ça qui dit elle et elle
n'est pas là là ne pas débarquer dans le
programme là elle les ai vus en amont
depuis janvier est alors suivie elle les
a écoutés maintenant alors il ya des
éléments que le téléspectateur n'a pas
parce qu'elle a vécu avec eux au
quotidien pendant un certain nombre de
semaines
partir ou deuxième jour mais je sais pas
si on ne va pas vous dire chaque sens
c'était le premier sur la télé partisans
de toi je mettrais cité de la samba un
montage mais que tu ne vois pas la
réalité des normes strictes isabelle
qu'un oeil de verre je le regarde je
suis en amour à ccc 1 millions d'euros
dont une fois fait parler
je ne donnerai pour ce soir une fois
dans ta vie tu vas arrêter parce que
c'est facile de me dire à bien des sur
scène six noms de la mousse et des fois
il fait des twin me dis que c'est bien
des manières qu'elles soient simples pas
ma copine et on se voile pas d'euros
soit quasiment jamais c'est vrai qu'elle
est bien dans l'émission moi pas je
déteste rené la taupe dans la vie
jacques août ses musiques oui c'est vrai
qu'à ce qui est saoulant avec isabelle
seillier suilhard in le marchand tout
est merveilleux etc
j'ai mon nez sais pas si tu viens de le
dire mais non on n'est jamais si tu
viens de le dire ci de l'année
euh tu viens de le dire le dire vient de
[Applaudissements]
ma vie en ce cas là de la caricature
maintenant ça devient du racolage et de
la bulgarie la raison est la manière
dont ça les issards jouvet claudine
hivin michel avait duré sept ans alors
je vais vous le dire honnêtement avec
les mots qui sont les miens c'est une
injure faite aux femmes parce que cette
femme est à l'affût cette femme à
l'affût un homme qui préférait la télé
plutôt quelques il a considéré comme une
moins que rien elle la pluie et elle
voudrait pour faire de l'audience les
rabibochages que cette histoire elle est
très touchant de faut arrêter de parler
de harcèlement sont tous galéré pour
récupérer l'anneau moudja peu d'accord
200 sms
karine le marchand c'est la belle julie
ardèche le premier a fat mais oui c'est
la bonne copine qui l'accompagnent qui
l'accompagnent dans sa démarche et cette
émission elle est sincère et d'ailleurs
je veux dire c'est une des seules
émissions il ya eu 50 des mixains des
garçons mais il ya une différence je
fais cette donne son avis mais les faits
sont là on est d'accord avec toi
le monsieur est très sympa la jalousie
géomines tube souple et élégante
il ya les bogdanov qui aimeraient
récupérer et récupérer leurs
combinaisons
[Applaudissements]
jaradi à mézidon voulant accablé karine
le marchand en fait il la défend moi
c'est vraiment à ce qu'elle a trouvé
sympathique mais moi j'ai un vrai
problème parce que la semaine dernière
ce pauvre eric c'était un mufle c'était
un goujat c'est un vieux garçon
insupportable hélas cette semaine on dit
mon dieu c'est un harceleur c1
lourdingue il est insupportable
donc en fait on jette en pâture ce
possible nous on est au zoo oil & gas
caouette et on dit oh la la il est
horrible comme l'autre là qui est sale
oh la la il est sale bon en fait c'est
quoi on regarde ce truc comme injuste
franchement il ya encore 5 6 ans il y
avait à peu près et un peu de wuala de
fraîcheur et là il n'ya plus rien tout
est maintenant allez passez alors moi
elle me fait de la peine
et pour l'un et pour l'autre ça n'a
aucun sens a pas d'intérêt ça n'a pas
d'intérêt
qu'est ce qu'un quiz book de nom alors
oui ce modèle franchement c'est des
maisons et tuent le hot seat l'émission
américaine the bonheur est donc prêt
[Applaudissements]
jal est compétitive